[Music]
you met President Obama Reese I did I
was lucky at the Kennedy Center Honors
mhm
we were at the ceremony and then as we
were walking out someone popped out of
like a secret door and they were like do
you want to meet them and I was like yes
didn't know who I was going to meet
maybe to my death a lot of times in
mostly in life if someone pops out of a
door and says do you want to meet them
you say no and then they just do this
and you slowly no it was pretty
incredible
um so my wife's British and she saw me
change into something she's never seen
which was this like uber Patriot when
you're waiting in line to see President
Obama all of a sudden you're like oh my
god yes yes like anything I will vote
for it this is the best country in the
world and you're so scared and he looks
like he's nine feet tall when you get up
to meet him and my wife went first and
she was so nervous to meet him that he
said oh hey how you doing oh my gosh I'd
really love what you do god I loved all
your movies intimate oh my god I so
appreciate that I so appreciate that
yeah
and I said Emily and she was like wait
wait
and so I was like you're acting very
dumb and he goes can't forget about this
guy loved the office and I went crying
so both of us have been blacklisted from
the White House
it is funny though that's because I went
see nobody I don't even think it has to
do with what what political party you
vote for when you're gonna meet a
president yeah the air around you
changes it becomes really intense it's
crazy
how come you and Grover Cleveland I met
Grover Cleveland his sideburns are that
long you know yes the year was 1898 no I
was actually with my wife and our two
kids and we did a function in Washington
and they said if you know just doing
this line you get to meet the president
and the president wasn't in the room yet
and then all of a sudden we heard this
we just heard someone say they're here
in like 45 seconds and at that point my
son who's six years old decided to have
a complete meltdown
and then on this I'm hearing that and
I'm hearing like 34 in 30 in 25 and he's
like just gotta put that kid down
sorry but that's what I was thinking by
shot take it
all of a sudden Beckett goes down you're
like he asked for he asked why but sure
a see he did the minute the president
walked in he like pulled it together was
like no mr. president and then you know
a minute immediately after the believing
the president secretary of snacks he is
secretary of snacks for the United
States of America and God bless
[Applause]